people like Gary this is all wrong I'm
nice and people walk all over me I'm
like let's break it down Becky let me
make it real simple for everybody here's
what's actually happening it's one of
two things one they're actually trying
to manipulate people this whole
conversation of I get walked all over in
the note you tried to give somebody some
[__] that they didn't even want because
you wanted something from them garyvee
see you're coming to Dallas let me give
you a ride to the hotel to save you some
money on the car translation hey dude I
want to pitch you [__] for 35 minutes
while I get you to the hotel that
happens every day people out here trying
to act kind they're using it as
manipulation don't give me [__] I don't
want and then ask immediately after
that's not kind that's manipulation or
number two you're kind but you're scared
to negotiate you're insecure and it has
nothing to do with you being kind you're
getting walked all over because you're
unhappy that somebody's negotiating in
business you could have said no but I
had to sell it for 40. I was like but
you said yes you could have told Harold
to go [__] himself you said yes nobody
walked all over you you folded because
it was a good deal for you